we'll get a founder that's like oh how
do i like
test my product before i launch to make
sure it's gonna work and and i always
come back and tell the founders the same
thing like
if you have a house and it's got full of
pipes and you know some of the pipes are
broken and they're gonna leak
you can spend a lot of time trying to
check every pipe
guess whether it's broken or not and
repair it
or you can turn the water on
and like you'll know like you'll know
exactly the work to be done hey this is
michael cybel with dalton caldwell today
we're going to talk about what does it
mean to do things that don't scale
the software edition
in this episode we're going to go
through a number of great software and
product hacks
that software companies used to figure
out how to make their product work
when perhaps they didn't have time to
really build the right thing
now dalton
probably the master of this um
is the person we work with a guy named
paul buhit who infrinted this term
the 9010 solution he always says
something like
how can you get 90 of the benefit for 10
of the work always this is what he
always puts onto people when they tell
them it's really hard to build something
or take too long to code it
um he'll just always push on this point
and
you know
founders don't love it
right would you would you say that's a
fair assessment michael um that's a fair
assessment yes founders hated it
tell the audience why it's worth
listening to the guy like why does he
have the credibility to say that to
people
well
pb is the inventor of gmail
and as kind of a side project at google
he invented something that 1.5 billion
people on earth
actively use
and he literally did it
doing things that don't scale so i'll
start the story and then please take it
over so as i remember it um
pb was pissed about the gmail product a
google product he was sorry the email
product he was using and so
um google had this
newsletter um product the first version
of gmail he basically figured out how to
put his email into this
google groups ui
and um
as he tells the story kind of
his eureka moment was when he could
start reading
his own email in this ui and then from
that point on he stopped
using his old email client and what i
loved about this is that as he tells the
story every email feature that any human
would want to use
he just started building from that point
and so you know he would talk to yc
batch and he's like and then i wanted to
write an email
and so i built
writing emails and if you know pb like
he could have gone a couple days reading
emails without replying at all so like
he didn't need writing emails to start
i remember him telling the first time he
got his like co-worker like literally
like his desk mate or something to try
to use it
and
his destiny is like this thing's pretty
good it loads really fast it's really
great the only problem is pb it has your
email in it and i wanted to have my
email
and b was like oh [ __ ] okay well i gotta
build that
a forgotten
solution
and so then
it started spreading throughout google
and do you remember when it broke
no what happened oh so he told the story
where like one day pb came in late to
work which is you know knowing pb
every day
you know and everyone was looking at him
really weird
and they're all like a little pissed
they got to his desk and someone came
over to him was like don't you realize
that gmail's been down like all morning
and people was like no i just got to
work i didn't know
and so
he's like trying to fix it trying to fix
it and then his co-workers see him like
grab a screwdriver and go to the server
room
and it was like they were like oh god
why don't we trust pb with our email
like we're totally screwed
and i think he figured out like there
was a corrupted hard drive and
i remember that point of story he was
like he says and that day i learned that
people really think email's important
and it's gotta always work
[Laughter]
and like perfect
cause i think the reason
i think the reason he did it man is
because he liked to run linux on the
desktop
and he didn't want to run outlook like
the google like suits were trying to get
him to run outlook on windows and he was
like
i don't really want to win windows but
yeah it was the dirtiest hack and as i
recall in this you know final part of
the story
it was hard for him to get google to
release it because they were afraid it
was going to take up too much hardware
and so there was all these there was all
these issues where there's a good there
was a decent chance i think it never
would have been released well this part
was that everyone thought gmail's like
um invite system
was like some cool like growth reality
hack yeah like virality hack it's like
oh you got access to gmail you got i
think four invites to give someone else
and these are like precious commodities
and it was it was another product it was
just another version of things that
don't scale they didn't have enough
um server space
so they had to build an invite system
yes there was not an option to not but
basically there was no option other than
building an invite system it was not
like genius pm growth hacking
it was like yeah well
we saturated this the hard drives are
full so i guess we can't invite anyone
else in gmail today
that's it that's it so you had another
story about facebook early days that is
similar in this light
so so let me paint the picture um
back when you started a startup a long
time ago you had to buy servers and put
them in a data center which is a special
room
that's air conditioned that just has
other servers in it and you plug them in
and they're it's they have fast internet
access and so
being a startup founder until aws
took off
part of the job was to drive
to the suburbs or whatever drive to some
data center which is an anonymous
warehouse building somewhere
go in there
and like
plug things in and what was funny is
when your site crashed it wasn't just
depressing that your site crashed it
actually until getting in your car
like part of being a startup founder
was waking up at 2am and getting in your
car
and driving to like santa clara
because your code wedged the you have to
physically reboot the server
and your site was down until you
physically rebuild to the super so i'm
just trying to set the stage for people
so this was this was what our life was
like okay and so my company i meme
we had a data center in santa clara
and there was a bunch of other startups
there as well and so something that i
like to do
was to
look at who my neighbors were so to
speak there was never people there was
just their servers and there'd be a
label at the top of the rack and you
could see their servers and you can see
the lights blinking on the switch okay
so this is what i was like and so
uh our company was in the data center in
this data center in santa clara
and then one day there's a new tenant oh
a new neighbor so i look at it and the
label at the top of the cage next to
ours you know three feet away the label
said the facebook.com
and i remember being like oh yeah i've
heard of this like cool like sounds good
and they had these super janky servers i
think there was maybe eight of them
um when they first moved in
and they were like super cheap they're
like super micro servers um
you know like the wires were hanging out
like it did you know i'm like cool but
the the lights were blinking really fast
okay
and so what i remember
was that there was labels on every
server and the labels were the name of a
university and so at the time one of
them one of the servers was named
stanford one of them was named harvard
you know like and it made sense because
i was familiar with the facebook product
at the time which was like a college
social network that was at like eight
colleges okay
so then i watched every time we would go
back to the data center they would have
more servers in the rack with more
colleges and it became increasingly
obvious to me
that the way they scaled facebook was to
have a completely separate php instance
running for every school that they copy
and pasted the go the code to
they would have a separate my sequel
server for every school
and they would have like a memcache
instance for every school
and so you'd see like the university of
oklahoma you know might you'd see the
three servers next to each other and the
way that they managed to scale facebook
was to just keep buying these crappy
servers
they would launch each school and it
would only talk to a single school
database
and they never had to worry about
scaling a database across all the
schools at once because again at the
time hardware was bad okay my sequel was
bad like the technology was not great if
they had to scale a single database a
single user's table to hundreds of
millions of people would have been
impossible and so their hack was the
9010 solution like pve used for gmail
which is like just don't do it and so at
the time if you were like a harvard
student and you wanted to log in
you would it was hard-coded to the url
was
harvard.thefacebook.com right then
like and so if you try to go to
stanford.facebook.com it'd be like you
know
error
like that was just a separate database
and so then they wrote code
so you could bounce between schools
and it actually took them years
to build a global user's table as i
recall
um and avoid this this hack and so
anyway
the thing they did they didn't scale is
to copy and paste their code a lot and
have completely separate database
instances and then talk to each other
and i'm sure people that work at
facebook today i bet a lot of people
don't even know the story
but like that's what it took that's the
real story behind how you start
something big like that
versus what it looks like today
so in the case of twitch
all
if not all like
most of the examples of this came from
this core problem and it's why i tell
people to not create a live video site
a normal website even a video site on a
normal day will basically have peaks and
troughs of star of of traffic
and and the largest peaks will be 2 to
4x the steady state traffic so you can
engineer your whole product such that
if we can support 2 to four x to steady
state traffic
and our site doesn't go down we're good
on a live video product
our peaks were 20x
now you can't even really test 20x peaks
you just experience them and fix what
happens when
20x more people than normally show up on
your website because some pop star is
streaming something
and so
two things kind of happened that that
were really fun about this so the first
hack we had was um
if suddenly some famous person was
streaming
on their channel there'd be a bunch of
dynamic things that could load like your
username would load up on the page or
our channel and the view count would
load up and a whole bunch of other
things that would basically hit our
application servers and destroy them if
a hundred thousand people were trying to
request the page at the same time
so we actually had a button that could
make any page on justin tv a static page
all those features would stop working
your name wouldn't appear the view cat
wouldn't update like literally a static
page that loaded our video player
and
you couldn't touch us we could just
cache that static page and as many
people as possible want to look at it
now to them
certain things might not work right
[Laughter]
but they were watching the video the
chat worked because that was different
system the video worked that was a
different system
and we didn't have to figure out the
harder problems until later later
actually kyle and emmitt worked together
to figure out how to cache parts of the
page we'll make other parts of the page
dynamic but that happened way way later
dude
let me give you a quick anecdote yes
remember friendster before myspace yeah
of course every time you would log in it
would calculate how many people were two
degrees of separation from you and it
would it would fire off on my sql thread
where you would log in it would look at
your friends and it would calculate your
friends and friends and show you a live
number of how big your extended network
was and the founders
you know john abrams he thought this was
like a really important feature i
remember talking about it guess what
myspace is uh do things that don't scale
solution was
i mean if they were in your friends list
you would say this is in your friends
you know so is in your friends list and
if it wasn't it'd say so and so is in
your extended network
there it is that was it that was the
feature
and so so friendster was like trying to
like hire engineers and skill my sequel
and their run into like too many threads
on linux issues and like updating the
kernels and myspace was like uh
so-and-so is your extended network
that's our solution anyway carry on that
but that's same deal
so our second one was um it would always
happen with popular streamers or second
was if you imagine
um
if someone
is really popular and there's a hundred
thousand people want to watch their
stream we actually need multiple video
servers to serve all of those viewers so
we basically propagate the original
stream coming from the person streaming
across multiple video servers until
there was on enough video servers to
serve all people who are viewing
the challenges is that we never had a
good way of figuring out how many video
servers we should propagate the stream
to
and
if a stream would slowly grow in traffic
over time
we had a little algorithm that could
work and like spin up more video servers
and be fine
but what actually happened was that a
major celebrity would announce they were
going on
and all their fans would descend on that
page
and so the second they started streaming
a hundred thousand people would be
requesting the live stream bam video
server dies
and so we were trying to figure out
solution solution solutions and like
how do we how do we model this how do we
like there were all kinds of like
overly complicated solutions we came up
with
and then once again kolinema got
together and they said well
the video system doesn't know how many
people are sitting on the website before
the video stream before it starts starts
trying to start video
but the website does
all the website has to do is communicate
that information to the video system and
then it could
pre-populate the stream
to as many video servers as they would
need to and then turn the stream onto
users so what happened now in this setup
is that some celebrity would start
streaming
they would think they were live
no one was seeing their stream while we
were propagating their stream to all the
video servers that are needed and then
suddenly the stream would appear for
everyone and would look
like it worked well and like the delay
was a couple seconds it wasn't that bad
right
but like
dirty
super dirty
but
it worked and and
honestly that's going to be kind of the
theme of this whole setup right super
dirty but it worked you had a couple of
these in ime right
yeah there was a couple that we had at i
mean so one of them
um
so at the time again like to set the
stage
the innovation of showing
video in a browser without launching
real player
no one here probably knows what that is
but it used to be to launch a video it
would launch another application in the
browser that sucked and it would like
crash your browser and you hated your
life okay
so one of the cool innovations that
youtube the startup youtube had before
it was acquired by google was to play
video in flash in the browser that
required no external dependencies or
just play right in the browser at the
time that was like awesome
like it was like it was a major product
innovation to do that yeah
and so
we wanted to do that for music at i mean
and we were looking at the tools
available to do it and we saw all this
great tooling to do it for video
and so rather than rolling our own tools
that was music specific
we just took all of the open source
video stuff and hacked the other video
code that we had
so that every music file played on i
mean was actually a video file it's a
dot flv back in the day
and it was actually a flash video player
um
and the entire it was basically of we
were playing video files
that had like a zero bit in the video
field
and it was just audio
and we actually were transcoding uploads
into video files
you know i'm saying like the whole the
entire thing
was was it was a video site with no
video i don't know how to explain it um
and it works and i do think this is a
recurring theme is a lot of the best
product decisions or ones made
kind of fast and kind of under duress i
don't know what that means but it's like
when it's like 8 p.m in the office
and the site's down you tend to come up
with good decisions on this stuff
so we had two more at twitch that were
really funny um
the first one talking about duress um
was our free peering hack so
streaming live video is really expensive
back then it was really expensive and we
were very bad fundraisers that was
mostly my fault and so
we were always in the situation we
didn't have enough money
to stream as much video and we had this
global audience of people who want to
watch content
and so
we actually hired one of the network
ops guys from youtube
who had figured out how to kind of scale
a lot of youtube's early
usage and
he taught us
that you could have free peering
relationships
with different isps around the world
and so that you wouldn't have to pay a
middleman to say sir video to folks in
sweden you can connect to yourself your
servers you you go i forgot what they're
doing it saves you money and it saves
them money that's what they wanted yeah
and there were these massive like
switches where you could basically like
run some wires to the switch and bam you
can connect to the swedish isp
now the problem is is that some isps
wanted to do this free peering
relationship where basically you can
send them traffic for free they can send
you traffic for free
others didn't they they didn't want to
do that or like they weren't kind of
with it
and so i think it was sweden but i don't
remember some isp was basically not
allowing us to do free peering and we
were spending so much money sending
video to this country and we're
generating no revenue from it's like we
couldn't make a dollar on advertising
and so we did is that after 10 minutes
of people watching free
free live video
we just put up a big thing that blocked
the video that said
your isp is not doing a free peering
relationship with us so we can no longer
serve you video if you'd like to call to
complain here's a phone number and email
address
and that worked and how fast did it take
for that to work
i don't remember how fast i just
remember it worked and i remember
thinking to myself
it's almost unbelie like that isp was a
real company like we were like a website
in san francisco
um and and hey that worked and then the
second one was translation so we had
this global audience
and
we would like call these translation
companies and we'd ask them like how
much would it cost to translate our site
into these like 40 different languages
and they were like infinite money
and we're like we don't have infinite
money
and so i think we stole the solution
from reddit
um we were like what happens if we just
build a little website
where our community translates
everything
and so basically it would just like
serve up every string in english and it
was like served to anyone who came to
the site who wasn't from an
english-speaking country and was like do
you want to volunteer to translate the
string in your local language
and of course you know people are like
well what if they do a bad job
translation i was like well
the alternative is it's not in their
language at all
so
let's not make the perfect enemy the
good and i think we had something where
like we would get three different people
translated and like match but like that
happened later we basically got
translation for a whole product for free
um
maybe to end because i think this might
be the like maybe the funniest of them
all
tell the google story because i think
this one's like the like really like
so
so look for the facebook story that was
firsthand where i personally witnessed
the servers with my own eyes so i'm 100
confident that is what happened because
it was me right
this google story is second hand and so
i may
get some of the details wrong i
apologize in advance but i'll tell you
this was related to me by someone that
was there all right you ready so
look
the original google algorithm was based
on a paper that they wrote which you can
go read
page rank
um it worked really well it was a
different way to do search okay
it worked they always didn't have enough
hardware to scale it because remember
there was no cloud back then you had to
run your own servers and so
as the internet grew it was harder and
harder to scale google you still with me
like there were just more web pages on
the internet so it worked great when the
web was small but then they kept having
more web pages really fast and so google
had to run as fast as they could to just
stay in the same place just to run a
crawl
and re-index the web
was like a lot of work and so the way
the work of the time is they weren't
re-indexing the web in real time
constantly they had to do it
in one big batch process
back in the day okay
and so
there was some critical point this was
probably on the 2001 era again this is
secondhand i don't know exactly what it
was but there was some critical point
where this big batch process to index
the web
started failing
and it would it would take three weeks
to run the batch process it was like the
you know
reindex web dot sh you know it was like
one script that was like
you know
and it started failing and so they tried
to fix the bug and they restarted it and
then it failed again and so the story
that i heard is that there was some
point
where for maybe three months maybe four
months i don't remember the exact
details
there was no new index of google
they had stale results so anyone any
user of google they didn't know that you
know the users didn't know this but a
user of google was seeing stale results
and no new websites were in the index
for quite some time okay and so
obviously they were freaking out inside
of google um
and this was the genesis for them to
create
mapreduce which they wrote a paper about
which was a way to parallelize and break
into pieces all the little bits of
crawling and re-indexing the web
and
um you know hadoop was created off of
mapreduce there's a bunch of different
software used and i would argue every
big internet company now uses the
descendants of this particular piece of
software
and then it was created under duress
when google secretly was completely
broken for an extended period of time
because the web grew too fast
but i think this is the most fun part
about this story
when the index started getting scale
stale did google shut down the search
engine did you
like that's the coolest part like people
just didn't realize they didn't know and
did they build this first again in terms
of do things they don't scale did they
build mapreduce before they had any
users no
like they basically made it this far
by just building a monolithic
product
and they only dealt with this issue when
they had to
you know i think this is like such a
common thing that comes up when we give
startup advice you know
we'll get a founder that's like oh how
do i like
test my product before i launch to make
sure it's going to work
and and i always come back and tell the
founders the same thing like
if you have a house and it's got full of
pipes and you know some of the pipes are
broken and they're going to leak
you can spend a lot of time trying to
check every pipe
guess whether it's broken or not and
repair it or you can turn the water on
and like you'll know like you'll know
exactly the work to be done when you
turn the water on i think people are
always surprised that that's basically
all startups do is just turn the water
on
fix what's broken
rinse and repeat and like
that's how big companies get built it's
never taught that way though right it's
always taught like oh somebody had a
plan and they wrote it all down and it's
like
never never and you earned the privilege
to work on scalable things
by making something people want first
you know what i think about sometimes
with apple
is picture like wozniak hand soldering
the original apple
computer and like those techniques
compared to like whoever it is works in
apple to design the airpods
like it's the same company but like
wozniak hand soldering
is not scalable
but
you know they earned because that worked
they earned the privilege to be able to
make airpods now and because google
search was so good they earned the
privilege to be able to create super
scalable stuff like like mapreduce and
all these other awesome internal tools
they built right yes but if they
wouldn't put that stuff first it
wouldn't be google man
and so
to wrap up kind of what i love about
things that don't scale is that
it works in the real world right the
airbnb founder's taking photos the
doordash folks doing deliveries
it also works in the software world
right like
don't make the perfect the enemy of the
good
just try to figure out any kind of way
to give something somebody something
that they really want
and then solve all the problems that
happen afterwards and and you're doing
way better
all right thanks so much for watching
the video